nasty brutish and short may describe
links in the Sontarans but not this
story classic doctor who reviewed time
time for some third doctor stop been a
while since I've gotten to spend a bit
of time with John Pertwee and I need to
thank my patreon supporters for this the
one that they selected for me out of the
options I gave and I gave them the time
warrior I love this story a lot a lot of
stuff going on here
this is during Pertwee's last season
that he was on the show it is the
introduction of the Sontarans is the
introduction of Sarah Jane Smith and
even setting those two things aside it's
just a ripping good story so what do we
got in this thing so we have naturally
of course the dr. Jon Pertwee the dandy
suave as ever
he is looking into or I'm trying to help
the Brigadier look into some scientists
who have been going missing from a
heavily-guarded research facility like a
place that there's absolutely no way
anyone should be able to kidnap them
from now Sarah Jane Smith shows up
because she basically sneaks in on her
aunts invitation in claiming to be her
aunt she is in fact a reporter looking
for a story because she had heard
suspicious things were going on here so
she's so that's how she gets on board
now what is going on well there's a song
Tauron named links and links crashed his
ship not in current a earth where the
doctor is but rather back in the Middle
Ages and he is using what little
remnants and functioning bits of
equipment are left on his ship to
project himself forward far enough
to get a hold of scientists and put them
to work fixing his ship so we can get
the heck off this planet again and in
the course of that he has also teamed up
with a local warlord by the name of iron
grande who is taking advantage of the
king being away on a crusade and taking
most of the soldiers of the other nobles
in the area with him and iron grande is
just he's taken over a castle he's
planning to take over some others and so
lynx is working on providing him with
weapons that are too advanced for the
time and so the doctor has to rescue the
scientist has to get these weapons away
from iron because that's gonna screw up
human history has to deal with legs
who's not a pleasant guy and we have our
adventure man it's good one
this-this-this
to date I you know I always make a point
of saying this so good so far in all of
these cases because there's no classic
era doctor who have seen all of their
stuff yet yeah I've got gaps on all of
them but at this point this is my
favorite third doctor story
I love the heck this thing so much so
first of all portray himself he really
you know I totally get why after Raj
Delgado is very unfortunate and
premature and that you know he felt you
know what maybe it's time for me to to
wind this down and you know maybe even
he what he didn't have quite as much fun
with it anymore if that was the case it
doesn't show in this performance he is
so charming he gets some of the best
third doctor lines in this you know to
the Brigadier you know this the quickest
distance between two points maybe a
straight line but that's rarely the most
interesting or to Sarah Jane Smith she's
asking him are you serious he says about
what I do yes but not always about the
way that I do it like oh these are such
great doctor lines and he's just God
think guys just swab and it all
he's tore eased absolutely terrific in
this and of course he is a bit more of
the action you know doctor he gets to do
a bit of his Venusian Aikido and and all
that stuff so you know there's a bit of
that I remember first time watching it
being thrown off by that because you
know I was accustomed to to the other
doctors who don't really do that too
much but and that is something that
doesn't vary of it's it's good and he's
he's just fun to watch the villains are
great too
first of all links is really good I'm
surprised how well the Sontaran look
both the the exterior armor look which
was a really cool fit because it makes
him not stand out so much in you know
medieval times when there are other
people in suits of armor his looks a
little weird but it looks like a suit of
armor so that looks decent enough and
then his actual alien Sontaran look it
still holds up surprisingly well it's a
little weird the first time he takes his
helmet off and he's you know that's what
the club's hangers on he's sticking his
tongue out for no reason he's gone I
don't I don't know why he's doing that
so you know there's little weird moments
like that but he's good he's got that um
he's got that that military obsession
he's got that nastiness about him that
is that is really good for the Sontarans
especially when they're when they're
your primary villains so I mean he's he
really is a terrific representative of
this race and the Sontarans are a
wonderfully fully formed concept they
they really are I see I see why they
were brought back repeatedly because you
know it's it's all here the probic vent
in the back of the neck the fact that
the Sontarans don't consider that a
weakness because it means they have to
face their enemies and they consider
that a strength you you've got this
whole thing this whole warrior culture
but at the same time he looks down on
the the you know iron gone and
his men but he has a thirst for battle
he was to see how battle is conducted
here it's it's just really awesome and I
love iron grande seriously he he's one
of my favorite Doctor Who supporting
characters like you know one story
appearance supporting characters like I
liked him so much that even hesitate to
call him a villain I mean like he's not
uh he's not a good guy certainly for the
era you know if Lynx wasn't there he's
the villain of the situation that's
going on but you know he's just he's a
man of his time
you know behaving the way that he does
and he's he's you know he's all bloody
like he's he's the perfect balance
because he's smart enough he's
definitely smarter than his men but he's
not that smart
he's definitely braver than his men but
he's not that brave so you know you get
this every now and then you see the
cracks and the bluster and he's just one
like it's a great double act with him
and his lieutenant Blood acts
all of those two honestly I would watch
the show that was just the two of them
I'm not even kidding I love these two
that much they're great double act and
and it's like honestly it's almost a bit
like a medieval Blackadder you know he's
got that kind of sort of dynamic going
on in this sense of like he's just
trying to work his way up and he's a
nasty piece of work I I get like I say I
make that comparison and maybe it
doesn't hold up at all but like in my in
my head that's kind of a vibe I get off
them I love them and I mean all the rest
of it looks really good because you know
being filmed in England they have access
to actual castles and this is the kind
of thing that the BBC at the time was
even on a low budget could do and make a
look good is these kinds of historical
settings there are actual castles all
over England that
to shoot it it looks good it looks
convincing Sarah Jane Smith has a really
strong introduction here you you can
sense in some ways though that she is
very much a deliberate attempt to go a
different direction with the companions
yet at the same time they're still
falling into some tropes so you know
she's not the subservient assistant
immediately asking what can I do for you
doctor you know how can I help
she's very outwardly and and you know
blatantly feminist that way you know had
some one point even talking to sort of
the head you know I want to say wench
that sounds awful but like head female
servant person for iron grind is like
you you know you should rise up you
should set up for yourself and it's like
yeah Oh Sarah look read the room know
your audience but you know that's kind
of just how she is and you know that's
not a bad thing but at the same time
like what could we do
Oh we'll be super progressive we'll make
her a plucky reporter you mean like Lois
Lane who was invented what almost 50
years before this hey you know it's it's
it's kind of oddly adorable that it's
it's it's a step forward from kind of
from some of the the female companion
templates up to that point but it's not
as much of a step forward as I as they
think it is but you know Elizabeth
Sladen
is awesome in this part she is really
good and even though you know she can't
keep up with the doctor she does a
pretty good job of coming to what I
think would be the most reasonable
conclusions that you or I would have
come to if we were in her situation
knowing what she knows but not knowing
you know everything that that was going
on not knowing what the doctor knows and
yeah she sells it really well like I
don't have any significant criticisms
about this like ie I could do little
knick pics like there was the tongue
thing
and like vid that there's a there's an
explosion towards the end that is it's
just it's just a really awkward cut you
know here's this thing that's fine and
now here's an explosion and they really
they want your brain to try and make the
connection that the explosion is
happening where the thing was the
cigarette it doesn't work at all so
there's things like that but like none
of it impacts the story it is funny to
be going back then and there very first
story that that the Sontarans have a
surprising degree of time-travel
capabilities because links doesn't have
a lot of resources yet but he's still
able to move forward and often time to
do this which I suppose is why in some
of the their return appearances in
classic era the Sontarans they kind of
had them doing weird time stuff like
that came up in the two doctors and I
understand it comes up in some other
ones as well
it's it's funny now that in modern era
who they seem to just dropped the the
sometimes ability to travel through time
from their list of skills which probably
for the best
all things considered it at this point
but and it is it is interesting dead
something to sort of think about you
know from me from now knowing what goes
on with them later but like seriously
just watch this if you haven't seen it
definitely watch it if you have seen it
watch it again it's really good and it's
not even that long it's only a four-part
er so it's it's about the shortest
version that these stories were from
classic era just goes down so easy uh I
love it the time warrior Jon Pertwee and
what I think is certainly the best of
the ones that I've seen a really
phenomenal episode what do you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about a whole bunch of stuff you
can do cuz his buttons and there's links
including one to my patreon if you are
feeling so generous if you're not don't
worry there's other
- you don't have to check out any of
them if you don't want cuz you know what
end of the day you're the council I just
run the meetings and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]